hey what's going on everybody what's
going on I hope everybody's staying safe
and healthy I this next joke you're
gonna see is a story that I had been
working out before we all went into
quarantine right and so you're gonna see
like the first weekend that I was trying
it and then at the end of this video I
am going to add a little clip of what
the closer is the end I had figured it
out after I shot this but I want to put
this out there just to show you how
things progress a little bit so enjoy
this video also if you're watching this
and you're on my page and you turned off
your notifications yo turn those mother
scratches back on we're about to get
this joint back up and poppin all right
so turn on your notifications so you
know when a new video is coming up check
out the video but don't turn it off at
the end wait till I tell you what mmm
the new end is all right I hope you guys
like this hey you want to see people
hate you cause right now yes good you
[ __ ] cop in this room everybody will
be like get that [ __ ] out of
here right now
there is zero
people who file up deep fly longer than
man when you hear someone sneeze on that
plane
the whole plane it's like the record
scratch so I'm sitting next to this guy
and I'm a cross-country flight
I'm flying from Los Angeles to New York
so I got at least five and a half so I
said to him I said you cover your mouth
that's just who I am I'm not gonna be an
[ __ ] about it but we're gonna talk
about it for sure you know I say you
happy cover your mouth that's what's
that's what happens when you're sick
dude like I've never had the flu had
been like oh my throat is so moist so
well who brocaded I so I said you're not
gonna cover your mouth you don't do that
now here's something you need to know
about me if you see me on a plane a
hundred percent sure if you see me on a
plane just know that the night before I
ate food that I know makes me for now
I'm not saying I'm gonna get on the
plane to start farting I'm not dude but
people fart and guys I don't want to be
the only person doesn't bring boats to a
gunfight
[Laughter]
if there's a shootout I don't want to be
firing blanks man I want to get in there
and honestly I'd rather smell meat than
you so guys a lot of eating foods that
makes me like you know like like the
kind of guys you have that's loud it
doesn't it's do any damage that's not
that's not my style I like miter like
yeah you know that kind of hurt a little
bit when they come back they're hot it's
like a little paper cut it's like it's
like a knife fight than your [ __ ]
one of those it just makes it yeah right
so I'm sitting next to this guy and I
just and you guys know it's common
courtesy in public if you fart in public
you're supposed to pretend like you
didn't on the plane you do somebody
or on the plane the thing to do is to
pretend like you smell it first and hit
the air because all you do is go that's
not what I did with this guy I and then
I just stared right
and he lets right at me if he goes like
this he goes you might want to start
covering up your [ __ ] mouth okay
I will tell you though guys you know
okay one more I will tell you my
funniest cross-country for Stuart what I
was on a red-eye from LA to New York and
I I didn't want I was bad you know what
it hurts your stomach and I was like I
don't wanna I wanna make everybody on
the planet uncomfortable so I'm gonna
wait a couple hours so everybody goes to
sleep and then and then and then you
know they will know is that and so I
waited like two hours and then I let a
couple fly and I guess the dude sitting
in front of me wasn't asleep
and this is what I saw well two hours in
out of nowhere in middle of the night
everybody else in the place to sleep and
his lead girl I guess Hey
[Laughter]
whoever's doing that this is a public
place I paid for the seat and I'll tell
you what I mean I was laughing I didn't
know what else to do so I just sit up
and on yeah because because my goal guys
my goal so badly
one day just have the pilot come on ago
this is your captain speaking
understand it's getting a little stale
back there we're gonna go ahead and
crack a window
I know you're doing 500 hold on to your
hats it's gotta get breezy but uh so the
part of me on the plane with that dude
coffin which was real I had switched the
ending all right not switched but in the
video you saw I ended it the way it
actually ended so that was the first
time I ever told the story so the first
time I tell stories I tell him exactly
how they happened because the truth to
me is always funnier than anything that
I can make up right so I tried that a
couple of times and then this new ending
which I would have said stay here it's
not gonna be funny because I'm not in
front of you and you're not drunk and
whatever I'm not on stage but the new
ending to that part of the story where I
had talked about him coughing you know
because my fart was so bad all true the
new ending I put in was he was going
oh man are you sick and I said nah man
I'm not sick it's just that my [ __ ]
is dry right because he told me his
throat was dry so it's a callback to
telling him that I'm not sick just like
he said he wasn't sick just that my
[ __ ] is dry seems to work guys new
video coming out next week love you
[Music]
[Music]